MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
103 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform podcast.
I am Mark Mandel, and I'm here
with my colleague, Melanie
Warrick.
Hello, Melanie.
How are you doing today?
MELANIE WARRICK: Hey, Mark.
I'm great.
MARK MANDEL: We're
actually in the same place
at the same time,
which is really nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So today we're going to have
a really great conversation
with Colt McAnlis.
He has a series called
Performance Atlas talking
all about performance on
GCP, which is really cool.
And then after that we
have a really cool question
of the week talking about the
differences between sustained
and committed use discounts.
But before we do
that, why don't we
have a chat about the
cool things of the week?
MELANIE WARRICK: I think
that's a great idea.
And I know one of the
main things we definitely
were excited about was
the fact that there
is multi-region support
for Cloud Spanner.
It has finally been released.
And it's exciting
because you finally
are able to actually scale
your Spanner instances out
to multiple regions.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
this is super cool.
I really like this one.
Not only does this mean
that you have lower latency
for all of your
users, but it means
that even if a region happens
to go down, you're still safe.
MELANIE WARRICK: Exactly.
MARK MANDEL: So
that's pretty sweet.
I love Cloud Spanner.
It's sort of really
cool in that you're
like, oh, I would like
something to happen when
a user does a thing in Japan.
But I need it to be consistent
when somebody in Switzerland
needs to see that.
And you can, which
is pretty sweet.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
So the other thing of the week
is that Kaggle actually ran
a survey where they
wanted to get information
about the people who are
using Kaggle and the data
scientists that are out there.
And they got 16,000 responses,
which is pretty impressive.
And they've already done
some analysis of their own.
It's got the data set that's
out there for others to explore.
Some of the interesting
points that they found
were things like the average
age of data scientists, which
is apparently hovering
around early 30s.
And just looking
at actually what
people are making in
different locations,
the US versus other countries.
And of course the US is a higher
salary for that specific role.
But yeah, I'd highly
recommend checking it out.
We have links for
the Kaggle data set
as well as a podcast that was
separately done on our blog.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Actually, so I
didn't realize this
before, they did the
survey but they also
released the data set.
So if you wanted to play with
the Kaggle data set on Kaggle,
then you can Kaggle it?
MELANIE WARRICK: Exactly.
MARK MANDEL: All right, cool.
Awesome.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARRICK: Not
confusing at all.
MARK MANDEL: No, that's great.
All right, fantastic.
Finally, we'd be remiss if
we didn't mention the change
in name for very good reasons.
So you may be familiar with
Google Container Engine.
We talk about it a lot.
It is now Google
Kubernetes Engine.
Reason being that it has now
been released that there is now
certified Kubernetes
program so that you can then
go, oh, this provider here?
It's a good Kubernetes
installation.
So they're providing
all the things
that the certification provides.
And once you are
certified, you are
able to use the name
Kubernetes in your product.
Since we are
certified, yay, we're
able to now call ourselves
the Google Kubernetes
Engine, which I'm going
to mess up all the time.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
We're both probably
going to mess that up.
But GKE now is
officially something
that you can easily attribute
to in terms of the name.
All right, so let's go ahead
and get to the interview.
MARK MANDEL: Let's do that.
Today is a very exciting day.
We are joined by one of our
most remarkable teammates, Colt
McAnlis.
COLT MCANLIS: Wow.
MARK MANDEL: How are
you doing today, Colt?
COLT MCANLIS: I'm doing good.
That's a lot of setup.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm really afraid of what's
coming next if that's the--
MARK MANDEL: No pressure,
no pressure at all.
COLT MCANLIS: Most
remarkable, gosh.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
guess the first question
is, why are you so remarkable?
Who are you?
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: Nobody, actually.
I'm a toaster repairman.
Or at least that's what
I like to tell people.
It's funny story.
So I'll get to who
I am in a second.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: [LAUGHS]
This starts well.
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah.
There was a legitimate
period of time
when no one really
understood what developer
advocates at Google did.
And so I would go to
conferences and they'd
be like, what do you do?
And I'm like, I'm a
toaster repairman.
And they bought it.
They're like, legit?
And I'm like, yeah, yeah.
It's my job to make sure
all the toasters are
networked properly.
And they're like, whoa.
It's amazing.
Seeing the people's eyes
like, that's your job?
That's amazing, how
do I get in that?
So.
Anyhow, sorry.
MARK MANDEL: That's
Google for you.
Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: Google "shoe"
and people think really
that we make shoes.
No, my name is Colt McAnlis.
I'm a developer advocate here
working on performance and data
compression, focusing dominantly
on performance for the Cloud
right now, how you can write
faster applications, cheaper
Cloud applications, take
your existing architecture,
tune it, make it better, make
it faster, make it cheaper.
All that fun stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I'm going to do it in
the Simpson's way of like,
you might remember me
from previous series
as Compressor Head?
Tell us a little bit about it.
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So there's a couple of
ways we can play that game.
Yeah, so you may remember me
from a series called Compressor
Head where the point of it--
I'm a huge cooking show fan.
I don't know if you've ever
seen Good Eats with Alton Brown.
I find his
cinematography is great.
I mean, the fact
that people can sit
down and watch a cooking show
and become enamored with it.
We tried to figure out how we
can duplicate that at Google
with different things.
And I thought to myself, what
is the driest subject matter we
have?
Data compression.
And I was like, how do we make
data compression and Alton
Brown work together?
And so we tried to break down
these extremely difficult,
statistically defined
algorithms that basically drive
the back end of everything
we do on the internet
and make it physical.
So how do we show
data compression
using sticky notes and
pet dinosaurs and markers
and sliding doors?
And that's kind of where
Compressor Head came from.
It's us defining the
basics of data compression
in these physical mediums, so.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It is a beautiful show.
I really like it.
COLT MCANLIS: Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
You did a great job.
Google Developer Studios
did an amazing job.
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah, they did.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The effects
and everything is crazy.
COLT MCANLIS: They take
all the credit, yeah.
They made me sound credible
and not like I was just
rambling for 30 takes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, that's amazing.
COLT MCANLIS: And they cut
it together really well.
I was impressed by that.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So you now have a new series
called Performance Atlas?
COLT MCANLIS: Google Cloud
Performance Atlas, yeah, yeah,
yeah.
So the whole point of
Cloud Performance Atlas
is to sort of codify
best practices
and give it out to you
in bite-sized chunks
that you can take back
your engineering team,
or just little tidbits that you
may not have gotten access to.
I mean, let's be
honest, building
a Cloud application is massive.
There's so many moving parts.
It's really difficult for one
person to keep it in your head.
And if you're using a platform
that's also as massive,
there's lots of little nuances.
And sometimes performance
falls through the cracks.
You don't understand
how to test things.
You don't know the
right way to profile it.
If you do profile it,
you don't know if you're
using the right set of things.
You might be introducing error.
Cloud Performance Atlas
is all about helping
you walk through these steps
for the common best practices
and get back on
the page of things.
MARK MANDEL: So what does
performance mean to you?
That seems like a very
broad topic, right?
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah.
Yeah, great question.
So I come from a game
developer background
where I was dominantly
focused on GPU performance.
So how many pixels can
we get through the frame?
Make sure that we're staying at
60 frames a second regardless
of resolution, and
all that stuff.
So for me, it all comes down
to cycles and operations
that influence your bottom line,
whatever your bottom line is.
So for most Cloud
applications, you
worry about different
things like boot time.
Like if you're a web
server, you really
worry about how fast
your systems can boot up,
how fast the content can
get from your servers
to the clients as
stage one, right?
Because if you increase
your web page load time,
you lose a billion in revenue
like Amazon said last year.
On the other side of
it, once you kind of get
that down you need to start
doing the next step of it,
which is, how can
we optimize our set
up so that we can increase
our cost performance?
So getting the same
result for your end user
with less operations or
in a cheaper fashion.
It's kind of a double
edged sword, right?
You want to serve things
and compute things
as fast as possible for your
users while at the same time
reducing cost as much as
you can with the least
amount of headache for
your development team.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I was looking at
the series right now.
And you've published already
19 of those episodes.
COLT MCANLIS: So far, so good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What are
those episodes based on?
What do you cover in general?
Is it more like something,
I don't know, theoretical?
Or do you get more
into the code?
COLT MCANLIS: Oh yeah.
So what we basically
do is, I get a chance
to look at some of
the common problems
that developers have
on Google Cloud.
And we get a chance to talk
about the real problems
that people are really having
in the trenches right now.
And one of the things that
was my favorite episode
was actually profiling
App Engine boot up time.
Just type that
in, and the number
of people who still have trouble
finding out how to profile it
is off the chart.
So being able to
actually sit down--
what we typically do is take
an idea like that, we sit down
and we actually recreate
a benchmark from scratch.
So we go in, we
figure out what we
need to test, how
we need to test it,
how we need the right to test.
Then we hand it off to
some smarter people who
make it look better, and
then remove all of the error
that we may have
inserted into it.
We show the A and
the B, and then we
figure out the
right steps forward
in case you find a problem.
So for that particular
example, one issue
was that if you were using
Python as an App Engine
standard, the particular
libraries had a larger
influence on boot up time.
So if you were using
scipi or numpi,
those took about 2x to 4x as
long to initialize and import
than other libraries did.
And so individuals
who may be doing
some scientific computation were
getting longer boot up times
during server spikes and
ending up with a massive bill
because their instances
went through the roof.
And the culprit was
really that they were not
optimizing how they were
importing Python packages.
So being able to sit down,
show people how to time that,
how to break out those
profiles, find the culprit,
and then optimize your
code appropriately
was a really cool thing to do.
MARK MANDEL: So how
did you profile it?
COLT MCANLIS: So for
that particular example,
we were able to get
those packages locally.
And then in Python you can
actually delay load things.
So a lot of people--
I'm not sure if
everyone knows this,
but it's import on demand.
So once you actually
call an import statement,
then it's global
after that point.
So we can basically go through
and time particular just blank
functions or no-op
functions and see
how long they take to initialize
due to the import process.
And then output all that,
create a nice little graph,
and can look side by side about
what's taking the extra time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Interesting.
So the test was actually
basically from the outside.
Sending out a
request and waiting
to see how long it
takes to actually start?
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah, exactly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah,
because that's
kind of the environment
we're dealing with, right?
I mean, a request
comes in, you get
a new instance that boots up.
And we want to see
what the world looks
like in that environment.
If we move it out
of that environment,
we run the risk of not
properly testing things
in the right way, you know?
Again, the opposite
of introducing error
is creating a false
testing environment,
and that's not
what we want to do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So this actually sounds
really interesting.
And now I'm wondering, these
are the common problems.
How do you know when
a problem is common?
COLT MCANLIS: That's a
really good question.
We have an amazing, amazing
support staff here at Google.
If you're a customer of
Google Clout Platform,
we have tiers of service,
we have dedicated people
to help you through
your problems.
We've got great
Q&A systems, we've
got great community managers.
This is a lot of information,
and a lot of common problems
bubble up through this process.
So if you can trawl through
it on a daily basis,
you kind of see
these common trends.
Sometimes these are our
big customers, right?
This is one of the
favorite things
I like about our
show is that we can't
use names of actual companies.
So we get a chance to
come up with fake names.
Like Tutorama is an
outsourced tutoring system.
MARK MANDEL: Of course.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
OK, makes sense.
COLT MCANLIS: Or Dobermanifesto
is a micro-blogging platform
for animals.
MARK MANDEL: I'd read that.
COLT MCANLIS: [LAUGHS] So
we get a chance to have
a little bit of
fun with coming up
with these names and
personas, and how that kind of
ties into these things.
And if we don't find
really good examples
from individuals in the field
and companies having problems,
we get a chance to go through
and look at the best practices.
Because, I mean,
we're all developers.
We've all been through the
documentation where you find
that one line that's
like, don't use /m.
And you're like, why?
What's going to hap--
I don't know.
So being able to go through
that and write a test
and show the performance
characteristics of that also
helps illuminate and shine
light on different areas
of our performance.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You were
mentioning before something
that I thought was really cool
because I had no idea, which
is, you were talking
about Cloud storage,
and how apparently
there's a thing,
there's one of those one line--
COLT MCANLIS: [LAUGHS] One line.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
--of documentation
that you will probably miss,
which is something about,
do not upload a lot of
files at the same time
that have contiguous names?
COLT MCANLIS: Sequential
file names, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: How
did you find this?
Did you actually read the docs?
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah, I
actually read the docs.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What?
COLT MCANLIS: Believe
it or not, yes, yes.
That's unfortunately one of the
things I do on a regular basis.
So there's a little known
system in Google Cloud Storage
that a lot of people run into.
So if you've got a system, like
let's say a monitor camera,
or you're taking snapshots
of a time series,
you typically
label the file name
with the snapshot of the
time so you can kind of
look at all your time stamps,
and sort them, and figure out
where things are together.
This is very common in
scientific computing,
very common in capture
based computing,
and things along those lines.
However, what we've
seen is that customers
who have that scenario
often get throttled
when they're uploading that
content to Cloud storage.
And they don't understand
what's going on.
They suspect its
a regional bucket
problem versus multi-regional,
the distances, maybe
it's parallel performance.
What it actually comes down
to-- since we found this,
someone actually gave a
nice talk at Cloud Next
'17 about it, about
some of the internals,
is that what happens when you
upload files to Google Cloud
Storage, we internally will
distribute them in parallel
based upon file name.
So what we do is, we use
that as a key to determine
how to separate it out.
And this is actually
really important
because if you're uploading
two folders next to each other,
each folder will then have
a different file name path.
We know then we can push
those to different shards
and handle the connectivity
for the upload.
So you get nice speeds when
we use this sort of process.
However, if you have sequential
file names in the same folder,
they basically all
can end up getting
keyed to the same upload
shard, which means that you're
basically bottlenecking yourself
into a serial upload process
there.
And we found this was
common enough that people
were running into it.
So we talked with
some of the engineers,
and we found that their
suggestion was to actually take
a hash of the file
name and prepend it
to the actual file name itself.
Not the path, but the file name.
And then what this
does is, given
if you use a pretty
evenly distributed hash--
I mean, it doesn't have
to be cryptographically
secure or anything, but that
will allow it to actually
get pushed and properly load
balanced across multiple upload
shards for GCS so you can
actually get the maximum upload
speed you need from there.
I mean, that's kind of
the little things, right?
Some stuff like that
you wouldn't expect,
you might miss in
the documentation.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: That's the whole
point of Cloud Performance
Atlas, is surfacing those little
things that make big results.
Basically, my job is to help
someone get promoted, right?
We want someone to
walk in and be like,
I just quadrupled
our upload rate.
And they're like, yay,
let me throw money at you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: How?
Uh, random ID.
COLT MCANLIS: Don't
worry about that.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
that's not important.
COLT MCANLIS: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Say we have
a customer in there,
we've hit a performance problem.
Obviously go to watch
Performance Atlas is
one solution.
COLT MCANLIS: Step one, yes.
MARK MANDEL: But say,
hypothetically, they
can't find their solution
amongst your amazing, amazing
content.
What do you recommend
for how they would end up
determining what their issue
is, or how they can resolve it,
or where to take it from there?
COLT MCANLIS:
Fantastic question.
So first point of all testing
should land in Stackdriver.
As far as monitoring
and performance go,
Stackdriver has a
fantastic suite.
If you're running a
continuous build environment,
you should already
have monitoring set up.
You should have a pretty good
idea of what your average peak
and alert based processes are.
Stackdriver can give you
all that information.
We just, in fact, rolled out
monitoring in Stackdriver
for your load balancer
so you can actually
see what requests are
getting cached and whatnot.
So there's a lot of
information there.
And we have fantastic logging
inside of Google Cloud as well.
So you can go through the logs,
you can see the exact numbers.
If those things aren't helping
you point to where a problem is
or an isolation or a unit
or a test case involved
with that, what I like to do
is start cutting away things,
right?
So if I remove
this from the path,
do we get the same response?
When you start whittling
all these things down,
you usually end up with a least
common factor of about two
or three things that
are chained together.
And then from there, you can
either do micro benchmarking
depending on where the issue
is, or you can go on to Twitter
and just send me
a direct message--
[LAUGHTER]
--and I'll usually
look at it for you.
MARK MANDEL: Colt
McAnlis is a service.
COLT MCANLIS: Colt
McAnlis is a service, yes.
And, by the way, I mean,
if you are a service
customer with Google, if
you're paying for support,
hit those people.
Because quite frankly, I get
a lot of my ideas from them.
They are way smarter than me.
They see a lot of these
problems on a regular basis.
And if I can't answer it, I'm
probably going to go ask them.
So that actually might be
a better path, you know?
Getting support from the
people who are smarter
and have way more
hair than I do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm
wondering, how often
do those episode appear?
And what's the plan
for the future?
What episodes are
you thinking about
that you're excited about?
COLT MCANLIS: So on
a quarterly basis.
We try to do one episode a week.
And that includes a blog
post as well as a video.
And then we typically
take the last two or three
weeks off of a quarter
to prep for the next one.
So in a year, you should be
somewhere in the order of 48--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
COLT MCANLIS: --45
to 48 episodes.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
COLT MCANLIS: If we're
doing everything correctly.
The future.
I mean, I think you guys have
seen my table of contents.
I mean, I've got ideas.
I mean, when you talk
about a performance
and you talk about stuff as
large as Google Cloud Platform,
there is no end to the number
of topics we could talk about.
So far we've talked about
profiling performance
for App Engine, profiling
startup performance for Compute
Engine, for Kubernetes,
for pod boot time,
how to profile all of that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
COLT MCANLIS: We've talked about
networking performance, how
to make sure that
you can get your 16
gigabits per second
transfer speed for your VMs.
How to properly size them.
We've talked about our load
balancer, our caching, our CDN,
the power of Google's
network, Being
able to test all these things.
Our next series that we're about
to launch is Cloud storage.
So we're talking about all the
gotchas and all the performance
things there.
So things like sequential upload
speed, large file segmentation.
Where I'm really excited to
go next is a couple of things.
First off is TCP BBR.
I don't know if you've heard
about this or seen about this.
This is one of my
favorite technologies
that Google has
put on the radar.
MARK MANDEL: Give us
the high level view.
COLT MCANLIS: Wow, OK.
So--
MARK MANDEL: Super quick.
You can do it.
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah, yeah.
So super quick is that
when TCP was designed,
it was designed with a very
specific framework in mind
for how the web or the
network should be used.
And there were
certain difficulties
with callbacks and windows
and everything else.
The web's different now,
and the engineers at Google
have found that there are
certain mathematical properties
that we can take advantage of.
So what TCP BBR does is,
by changing and updating
some of the transfer protocols
in your Linux kernel,
you can get a 30% to 50%
performance improvement.
And that's not just
to other VMs that
have TCP BBR, that's other
systems or other APIs that
may just be using regular TCP.
So this is kind of like a
free boost in performance
when you're doing
network transfer.
I'm very much talking
with waving hands here
because there's a lot
of amazing details,
and a lot of brilliant
engineers who
have put a lot of
brilliant time into this.
So if any of you
are listening, I'm
really sorry for
everything I got wrong.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Also, come talk to us.
COLT MCANLIS: Yes,
come talk to us, yeah.
So TCP BBR, I tell you,
since the next announcement
for Spanner, I'm really itching
to get my hands into Spanner.
MARK MANDEL: Oh yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: I really
want to see how that
performs at a global level.
I want to find those edge cases.
Because as people
roll onto it, there's
always a teeth gnashing
process, you know?
There's always, this
doesn't fit my mental model.
And man, I really want
to get my hands in there.
Cloud Functions is
another great one.
I really want to see the
performance there, figure out
how that's working.
And one other thing that
I'm really interested in--
and I don't know how
valuable this is,
but I really want
to figure out if we
can fix a lot of the
performance problems
with hosting WordPress on GCP.
We're already amazingly
fast, but are there
things that you can do
as a WordPress author
that GCP may give you access
to in terms of performance,
serving cost, DDoS resilience,
global availability?
From a performance level, these
are really important things,
you know?
And hosting it on GCP, you kind
of get a lot of that for free.
So these are some of the ideas.
Beginning of 2018
you'll probably
see some of these things
start trickling out.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very nice.
Now you mention
performance for WordPress,
many of our listeners, they not
only use Google Cloud Platform,
but they also use
also other providers.
COLT MCANLIS: Oh, fantastic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Do you
think that your series
helps understand performance
in general also for the Clouds?
Like is this something that
the skills that I'm learning,
I can apply them to--
profiling, I don't know,
my own machines or whatever?
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah, I really
hope so, to be honest with you.
So when we do a set, like
before we talk about networking
and the details of
Google specific,
we typically have
one episode where
we talk about the big picture.
Like, how should you even
profile networking, right?
If you upload some
data and you time
it with iPerf, is that a good
number or is that a bad number?
Should I be looking
at throughput?
Should I be looking at ping?
So we typically have
a bubble up episode.
Traditionally the YouTube
comments are like,
why would you do
something so simple?
Well, this is
important information.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: And
then from there, we
start getting a
little bit deeper
into Google level specifics.
But we always try to put
a nugget in there that's
like, hey, at the high level,
here's how this thing works.
And for the videos, you'll
typically find those much
higher level, much more
TL;DR. And the documents,
the articles that we link
with it are a little bit more
in detail.
You'll actually see source
code there, stuff you can copy
paste, some deeper graphs, a
little bit more explanation
of how some of Google's
stuff internally works.
So my hope for the users who
may be using other providers
is that they get a sense
of how things are working
under the hood with
GCP, understand some
of those technological changes.
So I've been doing performance
stuff for a long time now.
Way too long, unfortunately.
And one of the
things I always find
is that the crux
to performance is
understanding how the
system was designed,
and understanding how your code
is not utilizing it that way.
The more you tune your
code to work exactly
like the system was designed,
the better performance
you're going to get.
So creating that mental bridge
between those two states
is really critical.
MARK MANDEL: So now I'm
also intensely curious,
what's been the strangest or
the most surprising performance
thing you've come
across so far in GCP?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hmm.
COLT MCANLIS: I'm
going to cheat.
I'm going to kind of answer
you, but not answer you.
So I won't say that
there's the weirdest thing
because if you understand
how the hardware works,
it's just a mental disconnect.
But I will say
the hardest thing.
I'll tell you that one.
The hardest thing, this took me
probably two and a half weeks
to figure out, and I had to lean
heavily on all of our Cloud DAs
at various capacities
to figure this out.
How do you profile the startup
time of Kubernetes containers?
Kubernetes is known for being
really fast to boot up, right?
You have shared images,
you've got prefetching.
The hosting of the image
to the instance or the pod
and getting that up,
that's taken away.
So most people forget
about the next step
when you actually have
to prop your containers.
There is a non-trivial container
boot up time every time
an instance comes up.
How do you time that?
How do you find that number?
If you have a bad actor
in one of your containers,
that can cause serious issues.
And in Kubernetes, you
can define for a pod
a set of init containers
which occur serially,
and then all the
other containers just
initialize in parallel.
So you can end up
in a situation.
Let's say you're a company
that serves DRM style media.
So you're an image streaming
service or a music streaming
service.
And one of your init
containers, which
has to occur before any of
the other things boots up,
is a DRM library that
properly pings and connects
with the services
so that you can be
compliant with all the systems.
That might have a
two second time.
You might be
pinging for servers,
waiting for someone else.
But because that sits
in your init phase,
it keeps the rest of
your pod from booting.
This turned out to be one
of the most difficult things
that I could find.
Kubectl.
Is it--?
MARK MANDEL: C-T-L. C-T-L.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cuttle.
MARK MANDEL: You're
right, C-T-L.
COLT MCANLIS: Is it
cuttle or control?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cuttle.
It's cuttle.
MARK MANDEL: C-T-L.
Well, C-T-L or control.
I'll go either way on that.
I don't have strong feelings.
COLT MCANLIS: Francesc is--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The real way
is Kub-cuttle, but it's fine.
COLT MCANLIS: I think this
is the new gif versus gif
in the server world.
Is it Kub-cuttle?
Kub-control?
Kub-C-T-L?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's gif, gif.
COLT MCANLIS: Gif.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Gif and Kub-cuttle.
COLT MCANLIS: I like the gif.
So, this was--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: His face.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: Little animosity.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Poor Mark.
COLT MCANLIS: Little
animosity in the GCP room.
This was actually
the hardest thing,
because Kubctl will
give you node boot time,
but it won't give you
anything finer grain for that.
So I actually had to reach
out to Terry Ryan and Kelsey
Hightower and talk
to them about some
of the processes they've
been through in trying
to boot these things up.
And it's all documented.
If you go to GCPA, you'll
find how we actually
solved this, and some
techniques that you
can use to do it yourself.
But that took a lot of time to
just kind of dig in and figure
out what's the mentality, how
is this stuff put together?
That was definitely the most
difficult, and kind of weird.
But nothing like we found
a ghost or an alligator
in the Google Cloud.
You know, hey, I'm not getting
the upload performance.
Oh yeah, there's an
alligator over there.
That's not-- nothing.
I wish.
MARK MANDEL: That
would've been interesting.
COLT MCANLIS: That would've
been amazing, right?
In fact, you know what?
That's the weirdest thing.
MARK MANDEL: There's
no alligator.
COLT MCANLIS: That we
didn't find an alligator.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, I see.
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
for the last question,
because we're kind of
running out of time,
but I have one question.
We had a meeting the other
day with someone pretty smart.
And he mentioned that
it would be a good idea
to ask for reading
lists from our guests.
So I was wondering if you would
have something to recommend.
Like, I want to learn
more about performance.
Sure, I can go watch Google
Cloud Performance Atlas.
Is there are some book,
some article that you'd
say, oh, go read this thing?
COLT MCANLIS: Great question.
Whoever said that is extremely
smart, and probably really good
looking, and has a lot of hair.
So I--
MARK MANDEL: I don't
know anyone like that.
COLT MCANLIS: Nobody.
Nobody, nobody.
They don't exist
on the internet.
So I got a couple things.
So first off, I highly
recommend that every developer
should check out a
fantastic book called
Understanding Compression,
written by Colt
McAnlis and Alex Haecky.
Amazing article
that will help you
understand data compression
at a level that makes sense.
So, self plug, self
plug, self plug.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: Beyond
that, I really like
the SRE book, the Google
Site Reliability Engineer.
For my background coming from
low level GPU programming,
the concept of a Cloud was both
familiar at a scalable level,
and completely alien from a
services and ops perspective.
So being able to go backwards
to forward through the SRE book
was really helpful for me.
Likewise, I forget
the names offhand,
there were a couple good
Cloud engineering books
that were published
in the mid '90s
along with TCP/IP Illustrated
and some of those things
that basically just
described the architecture
of the internet to help
you understand things
along the lines of how caching
works, and how second rate
providers work, and where
your bandwidth comes from,
and latency, and all
that other stuff.
I forget those names.
I'll probably try to find them.
We can put links--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We'll have links
to those in the show
notes, for sure.
COLT MCANLIS: And if
you can't find those
and you can't find
it in a book form,
just go read everything Ilya
Grigorik has ever written.
MARK MANDEL: Ilya's great.
COLT MCANLIS: Ilya is Batman.
So I had the pleasure of working
with Ilya for a number of years
on the Chrome team.
Ilya was always amazing
because you would never
see him until you needed him,
and then he would appear.
It's like, man, I really wish
we had a solve for this thing.
And then Ilya's there like, oh,
by the way, here's the code.
And then would just disappear
off in the weeds again.
I think he is Batman.
He's Google's Batman.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We had him
for an episode on HTTP/2.
That was amazing.
That was really good.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
It sounds like you've plugged
everything, but is there--
[LAUGHTER]
--anything else that you might
want to add before we wrap up,
or something you might
want to mention or comment
on or anything?
COLT MCANLIS: So tonight
we're recording this--
I don't know if this is
revealing behind the scene,
but we're recording this
on talk like a Pirate Day.
So yarr, thank you,
mateys, for having me in.
Tonight we're actually
doing Perf Like a Pirate,
which is an event we
try to do every year
or so where we get an excuse
to get everybody in one room,
talk like pirates, and
talk about performance.
And hopefully the videos
will be up on YouTube soon,
but we've got some
great speakers tonight,
including myself, Jen Tong,
Aja Hammerly, Todd Kerpelman,
all talking about various
parts of Cloud Performance,
statistics, tracing, all
those other great things.
Really excited about that.
There's something a lot of
people don't know about.
We're starting to
trickle it out,
but Reto Meier and
I have been working
on a new series of content.
So if you have seen
his Pivotal series
in the past or my
Android Performance
Patterns or our
notorious zombie video,
keep an eye on the Google
Cloud YouTube channel
is what I'm saying.
Go subscribe, click the
button, wait for it.
It's good.
It's coming.
MARK MANDEL: It's coming.
COLT MCANLIS: It's coming.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Coming.
COLT MCANLIS: Yes, it's
going to be amazing.
(WHISPERING) Amazing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
This was amazing.
Thanks so much for
taking the time today
to tell us a little bit about,
really, yourself and everything
you do.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: Thank you.
Thank you all for inviting me.
I got to tell you, I'm
honored to be here.
The GCP podcast is amazing,
and we hear about it
from everybody.
So I'm actually humbled that
you all would at least let me
in the room.
It's just like being in
the royal palace, like ah!
Oh,
MARK MANDEL: Aw.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Just for once.
COLT MCANLIS: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Aw,
that was so nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you so much.
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah, thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
thanks, Colt. That
was a great interview, and
we appreciate the insights
and the overview
that you're providing
around performance for GCP.
So moving on to our
question of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So we talked about this
a little bit before.
A couple of different
discounts that are available
primarily for
Compute Engine, those
are both sustained and
committed use discounts.
They're both cool, so we
want to make sure that you
save as much money as possible.
Customers tend to like that.
So sustained discounts is
pretty straightforward.
If you're using a virtual
machine or virtual machines
and you use them over
a period of time,
Google will
specifically give you
a discount of up to 30%
net for instances that
run up to the entire month.
And there's sort of a sliding
scale on that as well.
So you really don't
have to do anything,
which is kind of cool.
You just use what you use.
And the more you use it, the
more of a discount we give you.
What's nice as well though is,
if you're maybe a little less
elastic in your load, or you've
been doing it for a while
and you know what
sort of memory and CPU
that you use over
a period of time,
say a year or three years which
is what we're talking about,
you can actually sign up for
a committed used discount.
So this is where
you're actually saying,
OK, I'm going to
agree that I will
use this much CPU and this
much memory over a year
or two years or
three years, and then
you can purchase that up front.
And if you do that,
you can get up
to a 57% discount off
normal prices in return
for committing to that usage.
So depending on
what you're doing,
you have a chance
to save some money.
MELANIE WARRICK:
There's definitely
opportunity for that, especially
when you have something
consistently being used.
Well, great.
OK, Mark.
We've got two under
our belt in terms
of doing intros and outros.
It's only a matter of
time before we actually
do an interview together.
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS]
MELANIE WARRICK: One day.
MARK MANDEL: One day, one day.
But before we wrap
up today, are you
going anywhere, doing anything?
Anything exciting in
your life coming up?
MELANIE WARRICK:
Anything exciting?
Let's sit down and
have a long chat.
No, nothing in terms of
conferences this week.
I just did QCon
yesterday actually.
So I am off the charts for
talks this week, which is great.
MARK MANDEL: Are you
done for the year,
or you've got some
more stuff coming up?
MELANIE WARRICK: I will
not commit to the fact
that I'm done for the year
because I find sometimes
last minute stuff comes up.
What about you?
MARK MANDEL: Really all that's
coming up for me is MIGS,
Montreal International Game
Summit, which is in September.
I'll be speaking there
on the 11th of December.
But otherwise, I'm sitting
still for a little while,
which is quite nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
It's nice to be in
one place for a minute
because it's been a
big conference season
the last couple of months.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
How awesome.
All right, well, Melanie, thank
you very much for joining me
for yet another podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK:
It's good to actually
be in the same room, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS] Wonderful.
And we'll see you all next week.